I have a question that's multi-part to
involve everyone so Zach I'm wondering
whether you think there is a fit between
algorithms and some of the questions
that Pat is identifying there about how
we constitute ourselves or is it just
the wrong enterprise and then I guess I
want to ask Alex whether the mode of
inquiry that your paper describes is one
of contract and consumption or is it one
of citizenship participation I'm
reluctant to give like a trite answer in
that I think Pat's
talk covered so much ground that you
know I don't know to say like algorithm
a role somewhere you know I think there
I'm sure you know you think about very
specific cases like you can come up with
some case where there's clear guidance
on you could formalize what you should
do it in certain types of scenarios what
I'm not optimistic about is the idea
that you know these things like like
you're gonna release like the just
algorithm toolkit or something and then
you know this is going to be like the
game genie like you just plug in sorry I
said 1990s but like you're just gonna
tell you know this is gonna be some kind
of interface you're just gonna insert
between whatever you were doing in the
real world it's gonna make everything
okay III think also that in most of the
cases that I've encountered like the
formalism the extent that it gets you
somewhere it doesn't it's sort of puns
on though like sort of I think every
formalism we've come up with sort of
punts on the the most difficult issues
if you look at like algorithmic
approaches to fairness it's sort of like
what we sort of say is there's all these
different condition
and how you would optimize them but what
it does then sort of say is like the
hard work is actually determining in a
given setting which is which is the
thing that you should be pushing for
which is the way you should be pushing
the needle same with like causal
approaches to fairness to say if someone
has done the work of telling you what is
a permissible versus impermissible
mechanism but like the hard work is
actually in articulating those not in
the algorithm
all the my clothes are your masher so
the way that we were going about this
starts with premise that the legal
system does not offer us enough guidance
at least in our understanding thereof to
produce an algorithm algorithmic system
or an algorithm assisted decision-making
system that actually provides meaningful
accountability or meaningful
transparency in the sense that might be
understood by the individuals who are
affected so I think these ideas of
contract law and the legal standards
that we've just discussed
they're extremely relevant when you're
thinking about what is the recourse if
someone has actually been wronged by a
system if the system isn't operating as
intended I think it's very relevant to
have these frameworks and have contracts
and to understand like in what senses an
algorithm and actor but the sorts of
questions that we were asking and this
participatory framework that we adopted
was to try to get some sense of
governance or design and have from the
ground up so rather than having these
governance standards of impose from the
top down like really looking at a very
specific context we don't claim that our
results are going to generalize beyond
the specific county where we were
experimenting and has some specific
characteristics such as that the
specialists are actually familiar with
algorithmic systems in ways that others
may not be and I think that the specific
community in which these systems are
deployed and their acceptance of the
system as designed and hearing their
voice in the original design and
development the system is relevant and
that's something that I don't think the
law really is going to provide us with
sufficient guidance on
because it needs to cover a much more
general case than we are any other
comments and questions for each other
I wanted to ask it
could you just say the last part with
your support
yeah so the last point that I was trying
to make is that we are working in a very
kind of specific and specialized context
where the specific concerns of those
affected and those who are trying to
draw into the participatory design
framework those concerns may not be
already articulated in the law so there
may become some kind of recourse like if
there is a contract in place in the
system supposed to operate a certain way
and those expectations are violated
right perhaps there's recourse in the
law but the laws at stance is not
providing us with full guidance on for
instance which features or how like
which features should be used by the
model how they are communicated and if
the interpersonal communications the
decision-making framework that is all
something that's important to the design
process but isn't something that's going
to be standards because there are many
excuse me your mic is switched off
because it there there is a way in which
the language almost sounds like what
you're doing is having them participate
in almost that resembles almost like a
voting system on whether or not this is
going to be put in place as a regulation
which is I would think a process that
ought to be within a governance system
or there has to be weighed against or it
has to be within the system of
governance that is not just about
contract or whether the product works
but it's a larger feature of the County
governance that's why I asked it is that
asking people as if they were consumers
or asking people as if they were
citizens and I just have to say probably
the hardest legal work I've ever done in
my life is representing kids in child
custody matters and I'm not exaggerating
to say it went from that to work on
civil war because it was less terrible
and to have a parent as I've had say to
me just wait till you have a child of
your own and you'll understand how what
what you're doing and how horrible this
is and that's haunted me my whole life
as a parent I can only say that this is
it seems not in the realm of consumer it
seems something more fundamental about
personhood and constitutions because
consumer law really is designed for
situations in which freedoms child
removal criminal consequences are not at
stake and so when you move into that
realm the idea that you would or the
company would have the ultimate say and
what gets done or not is is a it feels
violative of what government structures
we do have and and that that's that's
what worries me
so if I may just clarify
we are not proposing that these systems
will make ultimate decisions about the
separation of children from families
what we are largely thinking about is
how to better target limited services to
individuals or families who would
benefit most from their provision and
now this involves decisions that may of
course inadvertently result in the
removal of children but it's definitely
yes
so inadvertently in the sense that for
instance through the so there's existing
research that suggests that equally
situated black and white families when a
caseworker shows up to investigate the
black family is much more likely to have
the child removed and the white family
is much more likely to be offered
services so even if the intention is
initially to risk stratify families into
for instance a bin that would most
likely benefit most from services that
isn't necessarily the action that will
result why is that inadvertent I mean
that that is precisely the question of
accountability of a system in law for
which their pathways of recourse
supposedly and so to some degree the
comfort board strikes me as being a vote
against a decision-making by one entity
as opposed to the traditional system
however flawed that says it's not
inadvertent it's part of the system
let's talk about the system and that's
you know possibly a difference between
saying well anyway my very much like the
intuition that merely translating the
algorithm into some kind of
comprehensible English is not going to
solve the communication problem that
sounds exactly right but I suspect it's
in part because the communication
problem is part of a bigger problem
one more from the panel and then we'll
take from them around and ask the
question of it's like a question be like
from I'm interested to hear from the
legal perspective about the governance
of this yes there's a I think there's a
somewhat belief I guess from the tech
side that in some sense machine learning
poses or the use of certain kinds of
technologies and his family proposed
like a certain new kind of threat and
that it's you know there's a question of
is the technology sort of emerging in
such as sort of like diversity of
application settings and with such a
speed that this poses a problem for you
know existing law which usually moves on
perhaps a different time scale to keep
up with it or you know well like is that
a is that is that perception which I
think I've heard before it sure like do
you do you feel that that's accurate or
do you feel like having having actually
lived in the law and not just in the
context of machine learning do you feel
like this is something that we've
encountered things like this and like
the existing mechanisms and the existing
pace of legislation is such that the law
can keep up with sort of having
regulating applications of this
technology I I don't think that anything
is new Under the Sun if that's what you
mean I mean I do think that that that
that the use of predictive profiling is
why there's again formally if somebody
said this morning it's illegal to
profile it's illegal but that's it seems
to be brought back in by using metrics
that place a value on prediction for
predictions sake and that's in contrast
with a standard that by and large
supposedly looks at the individual in
the present moment in a variety that
that is sure
of associations Assurant of lineage
that's not what my understanding of
these these metrics do and you know it's
it's you look for example the Boston
Police Department has a series of
metrics it used to decide who's in a
gang or not and that goes into
algorithms and it includes you know what
your classmates are doing what you know
what colors you're wearing whether or
not you've what school you've gone to
there's certainly a lot of suspicion
that many of these algorithms are based
on where you live what your parents did
I mean particularly the the child
removal it's what your parents did you
know where you know the the you know how
many contacts with social services
you've had in your family not just you
so you can be born into a family with
this and that already is a certain
numerical value so the critique is not
simply about the algorithms it's about
the same use of information that perhaps
individuals are doing that was that
people distrust the the system itself my
concern is that it bakes it in at a much
more efficient level and because so many
not everything are proprietary or even
if public are we really going to protest
it anymore than we did in the and in the
world as it was before if you assume
that everybody is going to do this
anyway that's another way of saying you
are innately inherently incapable of
being a full human being a fuel citizen
and and and so that's the larger that's
the larger concern I have Martha - yeah
I do I mean it's related very much to
what Pat just said I think your question
is a really fundamental one and I think
that there are three ways in which this
moment seems somewhat different than
prior moments one is that maybe it's
simply a matter of degree rather than
kind that there's an emphasis on
prediction rather than retrospective
evaluation and maybe lawyers and society
we kidded ourselves that it's always
been prediction we're predicting whether
or not this person who's testifying in
court is
more likely to be telling the truth but
does that in the future it tends to be
in the president's about them in the
past I don't know I mean we at least
have told ourselves that we are making
decisions about actual events that
occurred in the world and what's the
right judgement about what happens
rather than predictions about what will
happen in the future
that's one end and maybe it's just a
more stripped-down version of something
that always goes on but it is really
stripped down the second is a kind of
outsourcing to experts and that's not
that's not the first time that's
happened I worked for a judge who very
much wanted to change the criminal
justice system and he thought the way to
do it was to give much more room for
psychological testimony and so he
defined the insanity defense so broad
that it could include economic
disadvantage stress community
experiences and after four years of
living under that regime and seeing the
experts testified with more and more
abstruse labels and taking the power
away from the judges by having the
labels he reversed the decision and said
no we're not going to do that anymore
this was a judge who wanted to bring in
much more factual experience and that
had nothing to do with algorithms but it
had to do with outsourcing to outside
the legal system to other expertise
that's less accessible to a democratic
accountability and that seems an you
know not unprecedented but it is on
steroids with algorithms and then the
third dimension that does seem to me
somewhat different is that the
algorithmic turn allows a bypassing of
human institutions so just think about
LinkedIn allows employers to look
directly at the picture and the names of
people we know from Sen Dells and others
work what the problem is with that when
the law says you're not supposed to be
taking certain characteristics into
account we can identify over and over
again you know
Uber's whole business model is to bypass
regulations so there's a Buy
passing of of the regulatory and
institutional regimes and that seems new
because there's self execution so that
that seems unprecedented Rach okay first
question from the audience can the panel
talk about governess of algorithms
defined incentives in both private
contracts or public decision-making what
are the dangers of allowing
incentivization what should we be
looking for what should be disallowed
any takers clarification of like
precisely what is meant here by
incentivization I'm the messenger
you might say that as you as you were
mentioning that because people are
affected by this they might change their
behavior in accordance with the way that
the decision is occurring and I was
wondering whether exist I mean obviously
this must come up in existing governance
sort of structures and I was wondering
like what is deemed permissible to be
incentivized like when like how should
we think about what we should worry
about when we think about algorithmic
incentives there's certainly the Chinese
credit system which I heard earlier or
somewhat somebody else referred earlier
I mean which is comprehensive and many
of you are probably more familiar with
this than I but you know you can't leave
you know looks at everything from the
time you were in kindergarten all your
report cards it gathers data on every
citizen whether you've jaywalked whether
you've committed a larger crime your
family associations it puts it all and
gives it a score a little bit like a
credit score a financial credit score
that we use in the United States and we
seem to be maturing tour that toward
that toward that system but it but it
the incentives that they build in our
for example you won't get a bus pass out
of your province if you haven't paid a
particular debt so it automatically
kicks into without any sense of due
process it pushes you one way or the
other at norms certain behaviors without
a sense of that is in my mind the
definition of what totalitarian or total
is a certain kind of totalism is that it
directs you in ways that all right at
Columbia we have a system of the canvas
system with which many people are
familiar and I when I was they were
training him I looked up and they had a
board in which they ranked the entire
faculty and I said what's that and it's
actually the conversations that students
are having while you're talking but it
ranks faculty by the number of
communications during the course of a
lecture I think yes well
but it's an abstraction of myself you
know they could be talking about the
color of my dress but it is taken it's
interpreted as a as a reflection on the
interest that I'm generating rather than
the boringness of what I'm generating
they talk about or it's supposed to be
better and then again spill down your
food and I'm somebody who actually tells
my students to shut their computers and
turn off their that so we can actually
engage
so I'm actually hurting myself right
this metric and so I'm being normed
that's at a kind of incentive I'm being
normed by this machine because that's
what you know my salary or my merit pay
will be will be ultimately judged by so
I mean I think there are intimate ways
of imagining with us I want to know
about incentives for whom so you know
put aside algorithms the introduction of
managerial judging where there's a
manager in the court system who will
tell each individual judge you're behind
your colleagues you are taking longer a
lot of people react badly to that
because they say oh it's turning judging
into a factory kind of activity the
other hand if you've been on the
receiving end of a judge who sat on your
judgment for two or three years it's
pretty horrible the first rule of the
Federal Rules of Civil Procedure is the
meta rule about how to interpret all the
other rules and it says all of these
rules shall be interpreted to advance
the just speedy and efficient
administration of justice I don't know
about you but they point in opposite
directions and so incentives for the
people in the system is one question of
course then there's incentives for
people who are producing the algorithms
and that those are very different
that I think like
one thing that's lost in the kind of
like statistical or associational just
kind of formalized fairness is a certain
something that's like a I think when we
talk about people and being fair in
their decision-making is quite
fundamental which is like something I
guess like something something more like
procedural fairness or how about having
those you're making decisions based on
relevant like there's not a notion of
relevance so it's it when you have a
purely statistical framework ago but
it's associated or not and then we add
to that is it protected or not but like
what's missing is that when something
like when you make a decision on some
basis that is completely beside the
point like especially in a sense of you
know were you to change it you would not
like you know you if you make a hiring
decision based on someone's like
sartorial choices that that's sort of
problematic among other reasons that
like if someone were to change their
shirt or something like this doesn't
make them a fundamentally more or less
skilled employee but now you've now
you've sort of imposed in this person
life that now they have to dress a
certain way and so then now you know
it's like a few make decisions based on
what movie someone watches or you know
people this there's this idea in the big
data it's like well their signal in it
if we just throw in all the data we can
make better predictions and you can but
the problem is that now people have to
what happens next is now all these
people have to live their lives
differently to optimize their outcomes
and you end up intervening into all
these aspects of people's lives in ways
that really are beside the point like
city and I think there's like a
fundamentally like just something
fundamentally ethically problematic
about that
so if there's a judge okay and you know
because you've seen a lot of his court
cases that he likes women with long hair
okay so you said watch a lot of a
certain way that's transparent so shop
he asks isn't it true that litigators
pay attention to what a particular judge
likes and the appearance of those who
are appearing in their court and isn't
that also an incentive yeah but those
are bad and we try to restrict those so
at least yeah it could be made
transparent but Brian Stevenson Mazon
tape of Sarah Lewis's vision and justice
yes and at the very end he talks about a
fourteen-year-old client he had it's a
very moving to I forget what he'd been
accused which was felt something very
serious but he was wrongly it was sort
of like the Central Park five it was
killing it yeah yes that fun and and
within and and there was very little
evidence but his whole demeanor was not
the sort of thing that was going to
please anybody and the first night he's
in there he wouldn't lawyer when Brian
Stevenson comes to talk to his client he
can't talk he won't talk and of course
in some systems this would mean that he
is recalcitrant or aggressive or sullen
and he kept and the lawyer keeps
pressing and pressing and pressing until
finding his kid bursts into tears even
great 14 times that night something like
that and and every metric of this kid
who was raised in poverty whose
stepfather I guess had actually killed
his they'd actually committed the murder
but at that time at that moment this kid
had horrible life chances by any metric
algorithmic or otherwise Brian Stevenson
stepped in took this kid under his wing
followed him got him the evidence I mean
it took an enormous it took resources
and care and now this kid is doing okay
he's graduated from college he's some
sort of engineer he
and he calls Brian every month to say
I'm doing okay I'm doing okay with an
algorithmic system those are the cases
that this kid would probably still be in
jail and with a bad judge this kid was
still in jail
but it also speaks to the power of the
exceptionalism that human interaction
enables that algorithms may not and
that's that's that's my concern so let's
step outside the court system I think
the development of digitally available
legal information is an advance for
Humanity and to to lower the costs of
people who aren't lawyers to have access
to legal information not to mention for
lawyers and that includes AI powered
systems where people can have queries
and could navigate systems
I mean it's I'm on the board of the
National Organization that funds legal
services for poor people and our only
hope is that we're gonna be able to use
some a I powered systems because we're
never gonna have lawyers for all the
poor people who need it but what worries
me is and I think Zack put it very well
is is the decision making is that when
you turn these capacities you turn to
these capacities to actually exercise
power over people's lives that's more
worrisome to me just one more thing to
my con I think so what had so
specifically as we switch to more
algorithmic systems or at least more
algorithmic ways of assessing things and
put things on that standard as opposed
to reflecting back on the standards that
have existed before this algorithm
equate him along we wind up pushing our
considerations in our dialogue to
quantities or elements of the decision
process that are more readily
quantifiable and this surely changes
incentives and a lot of the things that
matter in these processes are not easily
quantifiable things and so now the
contest becomes here's my metric for
success of an algorithm and I'm gonna
assess human decisions by that same
standard I think a lot is lost and we
lose a lot of the social values that we
wish to have you in the system simply
because our quantification does not
allow us to articulate those elements
I'm gonna give Helen the last word slash
question because we remember we need to
end on time because one of the panelists
has to go thanks a lot my question was
to inchoate to write on a piece of paper
that hopefully it'll be meaningful and
it's it's something that Zack kind of
raised but actually it also came up I
think in Jonathan Cahn's
talk yesterday about how formalism is
good and it creates efficiencies but
often times there's kind of a remainder
and and I mean I'm okay this is crass
but if you think about the way Facebook
uses a concept friend the problem and I
think this gets a little bit too both
work what Martha and what that said so
it standardly now we accept these
different modes of governance and one of
them is tech I mean I would like to
expand it and rather talk about artifact
as as a regulator but tech being within
that and to say that this that I think
it's dangerous to put all these forces
side by side as if like there's this
this listeners because what often is
happening in tech and getting to Zacks
concerns and now to pet is that we
reduce we have to reduce so instead of
having a human you've got a profile and
we have these massive systems and I use
behavioral advertising as one of these
where we we require humans to be and
I've been you know giving talks with
this concept machine-readable in order
for the system to work but you're using
a very reduced notion of the human in
order for the human to be machine
readable in the system but nevertheless
as you mentioned the the machine is
making decisions about this machine
readable human and humans have to accept
this machine readability because if you
reject it you're out of the system
completely and that's also not great and
so I think I don't know my question
is are we going to be able to escape
this can we can we look at these systems
and say they're viewing us in a very
partial way they're making decisions
about us it's very dangerous efficiency
which is the name of the game is not the
only value that we need to be concerned
about so it's really kind of is there a
way other version do you
well it may be crude but I as I
mentioned before I think that there's a
kind of standard list for liberal
democracies about what is good
governance and efficiency is one of
seven elements and it may cut in the
opposite direction of some of the others
where participation and efficiency are
certainly not consistent you know the
problem with socialism is too many
meetings and you know and responsive and
inclusive and having a sense of
complying with the rule of law well the
rule of law is more than a set of rules
it's a set of norms and attitudes and
institutions so it's it's you know being
legible to a machine may produce some
improvements if the comparison is the
Department of Motor Vehicles where I
don't know what your experience is but
mine has been pretty awful so it's all
compared to what but where there are
important issues in people's lives being
treated as a human being as a distinct
person as someone with dignity as a
person who can participate as a person
whose inclusion matters who is
constitutive of the enterprise that I
don't think we've been able to do yet I
had this experience of going into a
doctor's office because I'm at the age
where they start looking at my bones and
you know I and my wonderful doctor who
usually talks to me face to face all of
a sudden his head was obscured there was
no eye contact it was behind a black box
you know and he and he and he was
reading the scan of after of my bone
density and and he kept his head popped
I said well actually I can't get a
result for you and literally the machine
does not recognize my bones and I said
what what are you talking about and he
said well I think it's because you're an
American and and I and and and so I said
well okay for this purpose why don't you
just register me as white and so I did
this sort of technical passing for
purposes of the machine
but of course it didn't read me because
I didn't have enough data on
african-americans for whatever reason
this is all correctable certainly I'm
sure but there's a way in which the
perhaps lower probability of
african-american women having
osteoporosis became a switch of doesn't
or does you know it became an either/or
it became a binary now the other thing
is that nobody ever asked me what I was
and so even though it was within the
machine as self-reported American it's
very clear that somebody in the front
office or the nurse of the doctor just
put in black but there was no
questioning about and my doctor who is a
fine doctor of many years you know would
have asked me the basic questions yeah
does your mother have osteoporosis as my
mother does what's your family history
all of that was substituted by the
deferens so literally the expertise of
the doctor it wasn't that the judge
couldn't make his own decision there was
an automatic deference by virtue of the
structure of the way in which the black
box is on his desk between his head and
mind
it's literally there physically blocking
our view and so I suppose the correction
would be we need more data you need to
refine it you need to ask more questions
all of that so I can be legible by this
machine but I'm not sure that's the
answer because I'm not sure I always
again it is the question of read by whom
and for what purpose and I'll just end
with the story of being you know a place
where I go very frequently which is way
off in the wilds of Washington State way
up the Hood Canal it's very quiet it's a
place where you know old-growth trees
and I can lie in the trees and look up
and field I think there's a German word
for this feeling but an Sam kite which
is you know the feeling of being in you
know in in the forest without any sense
it there's a sense of the sky and you're
close to nature you know it's it's a
feeling you don't get anyplace else it
and it's and it's you you can leave your
body in some sense you can absolutely
forget who you are so there's almost a
sense of self melting into the surround
in this way that isn't somebody always
looking at you well recently they
apparently put a camera in the trees
that's what they put a camera in the
trees to parently look for people who
are invading upon fishing grounds are
going to be poaching salmon and so all
of a sudden it changed my relationship I
can't relax in the woods anymore and not
in those woods and they're very clearly
places on the planet where that sense of
not being monitored and it isn't that
I'm doing anything wrong but it's it
affected my whole sense of relation to
the environment to the ecology and I
think that's a quality that we're losing
even when the algorithms are entirely
bright well I would like a world where
the doctor has a handheld device and so
it's able to talk to you and can ask the
questions and also has engaged in enough
rigorous education to not be deferring
to a machine into the algorithms but
treats it as assistance and maybe is
having more time to have actual
conversation with you and I think we
could imagine something like that in law
but we are so far from that because
money and saving time the same it's just
much much more dominant in the way that
the incentive structure currently works
Helen's questions like Oh
fundamental it's very it's sort of so
expensive it's hard to I just sort of
restated make sure I sort of I'm on the
same page right I think there was
addressing both the ways in which the
way we are represented within these
technical systems is extreme
and in the ways in which we are values
like sort of express our values visibly
like how these systems should operate is
also itself somewhat reductive and
there's question of will you get better
or do we have a way of opting out or
bettering our position within it and I
guess I don't have a guess if I had a
satisfying answer to that I would feel
more accomplished than I do but I don't
have a satisfying answer I don't know I
think a lot in jizan who holds power and
what their incentives are you know like
to the extent that were represented in a
way that is richer or in a way that
benefits us more like this is sort of
yeah and I guess like you know in terms
of opting out like I had a sort of
related experience that I spent the last
month in Taiwan and I tried to kick some
of my like dependence on my cellphone
and technology for something that time
and among other things I discovered it
was like there are certain things that
you are like I felt a certain kind of
existential like fright that there a
whole set of services that you're sort
of denied access to if you don't it's
like you can't get on the high-speed
rail without you can't kick the
cellphone and take the high-speed rail
because the ticket that you bought on
your computer cannot be accessed without
having a cellphone for the QR code at
the station and so there's a certain way
that these systems are created in a way
that with maybe no individual centrioles
they you know actor making a decision so
many of these systems you know I don't
have any great answers and we're all
gonna die I just want to comment before
we close the panel that yes the
representation of an individual is
reductive but all representations of
individuals are
dov a human's referee of you is also
reductive and so I think I'll just close
with that observation and there may even
be more information that's a different
you're absolutely right that's
absolutely true but I'm happen to be
fascinated with the other topic so I
thought I would mention it that's why
privacy is so important because there is
something violative about always being
seen and it's precisely because even a
person gazing at me is reductive and
sometimes it's just nice to retreat you
know to beyond gaze and this this this
the architecture of what we're setting
up never permits you know what
historically was the realm of privacy
but it's also a realm of certain kinds
of human flourishing which includes
normative violations like creativity in
innovation and reinvention and
self-determination
so so first let's thank the panelists I
think that the schedule has a break on
it can someone tell me for how long and
while you're looking that up I'll put a
couple of I'll cede the board with a
couple of topics for for small
discussion groups and we have the break